BRIAN KRAUS: You are listening
to "These Vibes Are Too Cosmic"
here on WPRB Princeton,
community-supported independent
radio.
Thanks a lot for joining us.
My name is Brian.
Stevie is here
with me on the mic.
STEVIE BERGMAN: Hey, there.
BRIAN KRAUS: And we have
a lot to get to today.
STEVIE BERGMAN:
I'm Stevie Bergman,
and I'm a graduate
student here in physics.
BRIAN KRAUS: I'm Brian Kraus,
and I'm a graduate student here
in plasma physics.
STEVIE BERGMAN: And we're the
hosts of "These Vibes Are Too
Cosmic" on WPRB
Princeton, 103.3 FM.
BRIAN KRAUS: So all right.
That's all the science news
we have time for today. I'm --
STEVIE BERGMAN: Outreach has
been a big part of my life
for many years.
I started a radio show
here, was given a slot.
And around that time, also,
Brian just kind of casually
mentioned, you know, I would
love to start on the radio
show, as well.
And I want to do a science
outreach program, as well.
And I was just like --
I think I called you
at 10 p.m. or 11 p.m.
and was just like,
oh my God, dude.
This is amazing.
And yeah, that's kind
of how it got started.
BRIAN KRAUS: Our goals for
"These Vibes Are Too Cosmic,"
to get to what
our show is about,
it's about spreading
science around.
It's about making science
kind of personable to people.
First of all, there's a
lot of great discoveries
that just will blow your mind
if you bother to understand what
they are and what they mean.
And to share these with people --
I think a lot of them, people
would never hear about.
This is "These Vibes
Are Too Cosmic.
We'll be right back.
Most shows on WPRB are
very music-focused.
And we had one of the first
ideas for a talk show.
So our show is about trying to
get the science research that
happens within Princeton --
often behind closed doors,
on someone's computer
or in someone's lab --
and spread it out to the public.
STEVIE BERGMAN: The
way I think of it
is that we provide a
platform for scientists
and experts, authors.
Sometimes we bring in artists.
It almost always
has a science bend.
But I think what people
underestimate is how many
things have a science bend.
BRIAN KRAUS: And here
to talk to me about it
is Isabela Morales, a
graduate student here
in the Department of History.
STEVIE BERGMAN: What we do as
interviewers is we try and help
the expert explain their
work and their idea
for just the general
audience that's listening,
whether they're just
tuning in for a few minutes
as they're driving or whether
they're a regular listener.
BRIAN KRAUS: It's
something we're, actually,
I think, as scientists,
it's a skill that we get
without really
realizing it's a skill,
but just to understand
someone's science
and be able to process it
quickly and summarize it.
And that's so useful for
a live radio interview.
For those listeners far
outside of Princeton,
Nassau Hall is the center of
Princeton campus, basically.
ISABELA MORALES: Right.
It is the oldest
building on campus.
STEVIE BERGMAN: Our best
interviews are ones where
we connect with our
guest, and our guest
connects with the audience.
And they are laughing,
and they are getting
excited about what they do.
Because this is what they
spend their every day on.
And they're so
passionate about it.
And if we can bring that out
and show that to our audience,
that is wonderful.
Science is everywhere, all
around us, all the time.
And so if we can help
people look around the world
and think about the way
the universe is working --
from the atoms in the
table, from the way
their car is working, from
trees, all of this stuff --
then I think we've done our job.
[MUSIC PLAYING]